what's going on everybody welcome to
part 4 of the neural networks from
scratch videos in this video what we're
doing is taking our currently a single
sample of inputs and converting that to
be a batch of inputs we'll explain why
and how momentarily also we're currently
modeling a single layer of neurons and
what we'd like to do is model two layers
of neurons which then we could
extrapolate out to however many players
of neurons we want at which point it
will become pretty apparent that we
would benefit pretty greatly from
converting this to from this code now to
an object instead so we'll be getting
into doing object-oriented programming
creating our first layer objects with
that in mind as a reminder this series
is based on the neural networks from
scratch book which you can get at em NFS
IO at the time of my recording this this
book is in draft form but if you
pre-order any version of the book you
get within hours access to the e-book
draft version which is currently in a
Google Doc so you can go in there
highlight ask questions comment in line
with the actual text also the draft at
some point it won't be a draft anymore
obviously the book is currently
scheduled to ship out September 2020 and
but right now the draft version of the
book is quite a bit further ahead than
we are right now covering everything
from obviously creating the the neurons
in the neural network creating a full
neural when I work doing a full forward
pass obviously with also activation
functions calculating loss doing the
partial derivatives back propagation
with various optimizers also
regularization techniques like drop out
in l1 l2 regularization so quite a bit
further ahead so if you want to get a
jump on the material or you just want to
review the material before or after with
videos that's a great way to do it and
again access to the eBook version is
given within hours I'm still doing that
manually so it's just if I'm around I'll
give access so as far as I know no one
has waited more than a day for the
access but so anyway let's get into the
code now so the first thing that we're
gonna cover is batches first of all why
batch so there's kind of two major
reasons for batches the first one is
pretty obvious and simple to understand
we can can we can calculate these things
in parallel so the first thing
allow that batches allow us to do it's
it's really a cherry on top I'm not sure
I think this is just kind of a nice
thing that happens I don't really think
this is the primary reason I would say
batch but because we're calculating
things in parallel the bigger the batch
the more parallel operations that we can
run now this is also why we tend to do
neural network training on GPUs rather
than doing them on CPUs so I don't know
what the average CPU core account is
these days some are probably between 4
and 8 that's not very many course
compared to your typical GPU which is
going to have hundreds or thousands of
these cores that we can actually run
calculations on so that's why it's so
much faster on a GPU so it's really the
CPU core is right those are meant for
much harder calculations than what we're
doing here which is typically like
matrix multiplications and pretty simple
calculations so so that's why we use
GPUs rather than CPUs now that's a
benefit of doing things with batches but
the other reason why we do things in
batches is because it helps with
generalization so so if you just think
for a moment so as a reminder what are
what are inputs right now it's a single
sample and that sample currently
contains 4 features so given our let's
let's continue the example of hey we're
trying to predict whether or not a
server is going to fail obviously we've
made up all of these values but just
pretend for a moment in that example
maybe each of these features is a
reading from a sensor so this could be
your temperature sensor this is your
humidity sensor value and so on so these
are these four values are values from
unique sensors at a specific point in
time so that's a single sample now we
can convert that to be a batch of
samples and have many readings of
sensors at any specific point in time
and then we're going to attempt to fit
those to something now right now we
don't have the intended output or
anything like that we're not calculating
loss yet or anything like that so for
now just make sure you have a good idea
of what what are these inputs right now
they are features from a single sample
and so this this describes the current
staff
of this server at a single point in time
right now and what we want to be able to
do is pass a batch of these samples
instead so so the second reason why this
is helpful is it helps us to generalize
because rather than showing the Machine
the algorithm one example at a time and
then it's basically going to try to fit
to that sample and then that the next
sample in the next sample we can instead
show it multiple at a time that way it's
much more likely to generalize and I
think the best way to understand that
concept is to just visualize it so let's
check that out
so to visualize the concept of batches
in generalization what we're going to do
is we're going to take a theoretical
sample set of 512 samples and then we're
going to ask a single neuron to attempt
to fit to that sample now what's going
on here is we're just fitting one sample
at a time to this neuron and you can
just see that this neuron is just
bouncing around with that fitment line
so that line there is the fitment and
the dots that you're seeing these are
individual samples so we're just asking
it to fit to this one then this one that
is when those one it's very confusing
and just imagine yourself if you were
shown just one sample at a time and you
were asked draw the fitment line to
represent the entire set of samples you
would have a probably a pretty hard time
doing it right whereas when we show
multiple samples or you can see all of
the samples kind of fading into the
background here you can see okay I could
probably what like if you just had a
better representation of all the samples
you could probably do a better job of
fitting to the samples so if we increase
the batch size to four we can see that
it does a better job there's a lot less
wiggling around and we expect that when
we're just showing a small number of
samples at a time that the fitment line
is going to move a little bit we expect
that but you can already see how much
less movement we're seeing so it's
already become much easier for this
neuron to fit this exact same sample set
when we increase the batch size to four
if we continue to increase to 16 we see
even less movement for the most part
right this this line is is pretty much
in the same kind of standard deviation
range once it catches up via the
learning rate you don't need to
understand what the learning rate is
necessarily doing here just know the
learning rate is kind of the way of kind
of moving forward so how much of the
previous
knowledge do we want to keep versus the
new knowledge or something like that
well we'll get to learning rates soon
but I think if you just imagine again at
yourself like if you are trying to
create a fitment line yourself imagine
you are the neuron if you're just
showing one sample at a time that's very
difficult whereas if you're showing 32
at a time suddenly it becomes a little
easier now you might wonder why not all
the samples at a time
this can generally the problem with this
is it can cause over fitment so if you
show all the samples at once
now you're telling them the neural
network hey just fit till all of these
and the normal network is gonna try to
fit as good as possible to all the
samples at once which is actually likely
to hurt your generalization because now
it's it has knowledge of all of the
samples and it's gonna actually fit your
in sample data it will fit your
in-sample data likely pretty good and
then do pretty bad on your out-of-sample
data so you don't really want to pass
all of your data at once and you don't
necessarily want a huge batch size
either generally something between 32 64
may be as high as 128 that's pretty rare
a batch size of 32 is actually a pretty
common batch size you know from what
I've seen different problems will vary
with batch size for sure
but that is the concept of batch size
alright so now that we're all convinced
of the wonders of batches let's convert
our single sample of inputs to a batch
of inputs so right now it's a list that
means we're going to convert it to be a
list of lists and then we're going to
match the values from the book so the
second sample here is 2.0 5.0 and then
it's negative 1.0 2.0 the third sample
is negative 1 point 5 to point 7 3 point
3 and negative 0.8 the next question we
should ask yourself is there anything
that we need to change about weights and
biases do we need to add weights or any
biases or anything like that just as a
general review of how things are working
so the answer that is of course no
because weights and biases are
associated with individual unique
neurons are we adding any neurons to
like this in theory is our layer are we
adding any neurons to our layer by
adding
of a batch of inputs as anything change
there no so we don't need to change
anything in our weights and our bias
scenes getting to the output is there
anything that we need to change in this
dot product we're adding the biases or
anything like that so now that both
weights and inputs are going to be of
matrix let's talk briefly about the
matrix product and how that works
essentially it's going to be very
similar except for the fact that now
that the inputs are going to be a matrix
let's talk about how that how we do a
matrix dot another matrix so to do this
what we do is we take that first row
vector from the first you know input
matrix so in this case it was matrix a
and then we are going to do the dot
product of every single column vector
from matrix B this results in the scalar
which becomes the first value in that
first row vector for the output matrix
so again still the first row vector in
that a matrix we're going to do the dot
product with the second column then the
third column fourth column and fifth
column of matrix B and these individual
scalar values as the result of that dot
product become the first row then we
continue on now we're at that second row
that second row vector from the first
matrix and so on until we've populated
the entire output of this matrix product
so remember in the previous tutorial
that we hit an error because because we
were passing inputs by weights right and
recall that the size at index at the
index of one of the first element in the
dot product needs to match the size at
index zero of the second thing that we
passed so in this case at index 0 so
weights is what it's a three by four so
that means inputs needed to be the four
by none really or four by one that it
was so now is that true does that still
is that still the case well no right
because actually inputs and weights are
currently the same shape so if we go to
run this
we're gonna see uh-oh right we get the
shape error right and again just like I
said before this is like a perfect shape
error that you probably would see fairly
frequently in other deep learning
frameworks and then you would probably
you know Google or DuckDuckGo search to
figure out what is the answer to this
problem because it doesn't make sense to
you but it's pretty clear if you now
that you understand how this works that
it's telling you right now you know
you've got a dim one here that's of size
four right so that's weights it's
telling you right now at this at the
first tooth index so the zeroth is this
stuff so you have three sets of weights
at the first tooth index well how many
weights do we have in each weight set
four so it's telling you right now
you got four here but unfortunately yet
then zero of inputs right you have three
right you've got three in this batch so
you've got three samples this is a
problem and it doesn't get any better by
changing things so if we refer back to
inputs by weights for example we get
another shape error because it still
hasn't changed we have to we have to do
something else so what do we do because
so let's go back to what are we trying
to do what we are trying to do is inputs
times the weights so what what's
happening right now is the dot product
is attempting to take this value
multiplied by this value then this value
multiplied by this value this value
multiplied by this value and then we get
to 2.5 and the dot product is like what
what do I do it doesn't have a value
instead what we're trying to do is this
value times this value this value times
this value and so on all the way through
four and then suddenly the shapes are
correct so how do we do this so what we
really would want to do is take this
weights matrix and we want to switch
rows and columns right that's what we
that's how we would solve this problem
so luckily for us that's called
transpose so again the concept of a
transpose is just to swap rows and
columns so all you're gonna do is take
the first row
that becomes a column you're gonna take
the second row that becomes a column and
so on throughout this entire matrix and
that's all there is to a transpose of a
matrix all right so let's go ahead and
transpose the weights now to do that
we're actually going to convert weights
to a numpy array now why do we need to
do that
so right now inputs and weights are
lists of lists in Python when we pass
those two numpy x' dot product function
here what's happening is in the back end
these inputs in this weight these are
actually getting converted to numpy
arrays but since we want to use know how
to transpose the weights we actually are
going to convert weights now to numpy
array weights and then to transpose that
it's actually just dot capital t boom
transpose let's go ahead and run that
and what we get is an actual batch of
outputs so we should be able to
recognize this one is this is the same
one that we've been seeing so far which
is the outputs from the three neurons
from this as your input and then these
are some new outputs from the same three
neurons based on the the other inputs
that we just just started adding so okay
pretty cool now the next thing that
we're going to talk about is adding one
more layer here but before we do that
let's make sure everyone's with us s4 is
what happened why do we have to
transpose here so before we move along
to adding another layer let's let's
review what's happened so far so
initially we were able to do the inputs
and the weights without a transpose
because the weight was a matrix but
inputs was just a vector so in this case
the shapes lined up we could do a dot
product as long as the weights came
first and everything was fine but when
inputs became a batch of inputs the
shapes did not work anymore because what
we need is index one of that first
element needs to match index zero of
that second element so once we transpose
weights suddenly it was able to work
again
so let's review the actual calculations
that have taken place in our example the
first thing we do is transpose our
weights so that we could even do the
matrix product then we take the matrix
of our inputs dot the weights which
means we're going to take each
individual row vector from the inputs
matrix and do the dot product with each
column from the transposed weight matrix
doing this for each of the row vectors
in the inputs matrix which gives us our
final output for this matrix product ok
so our final calculation is to add this
biases row vector to our matrix product
output from the inputs and the
transposed weights to add a row vector
to a matrix all we need to do is we are
going to just add this biases row vector
to each of the rows from that matrix
product output to do that all you're
doing is adding each element together so
at the same index so it's 2.8 plus 2 6.9
plus 3 and negative 0.5 to 9 plus 0.5 ok
so now what we're gonna do is add
another layer and to do that we just
need another set of weights and biases
and then basically the size of weights
that's how many neurons we're gonna have
the length or size of bias ease again
that's how many neurons we're gonna have
so for now we'll just go with the exact
same size layer just for simplicity sake
and just so you understand how this is
kind of working and then what we'll do
is convert this to an object so again
like before I am going to copy the
values from the book so we're gonna say
zero point one negative zero point
fourteen zero point five for that first
set of weights the second set of weights
will be negative zero point five zero
point twelve negative zero point three
three in that final set of weights is
going to be negative zero point four
four zero point seven three and negative
zero point one three and then finally
the biases that will go with negative 1
2 and negative zero point five so that
is for our second layer now what we're
going to do is rather than just calling
this straight-up output we're going to
call this layer
layer1 underscore outputs so this is now
the outputs of layer 1 which then become
the inputs for layer 2 so all we're
going to say is what we're gonna do is
we're going to take this line copy we
paste this line and then we're going to
rather than inputs here this becomes
layer 1 inputs we'll call this layer 2
outputs and then so the inputs change
now to be the inputs from layer 1 now
what we want to do is take weights to
biases 2 and then what we can do is we
can print you know layer 2 outputs at
this point go ahead and run that and
just to confirm that is the same from
the book yes it is cool so okay so
that's as easy as adding another layer
now of course you know you might want to
be able to really quickly change the
size of that layer like how many neurons
are you gonna have and adding more
layers and of course at this point we
should hopefully recognize that this is
very quickly going to be quite quite
unruly so instead of doing things this
way what we're going to do is convert
this to be an object right so to convert
the concept of layers up to this point
what we're gonna do is we'll keep inputs
and these will be this will serve as
actually our sample data and instead
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
delete basically all of this and we will
start coding the other thing I will do
is I'm gonna I'm gonna change the name
of inputs to X as a capital X it's kind
of a standard with machine learning that
your your input feature sets is going to
be denoted by a capital X so you'll have
X and maybe you'll have X train and X
test and so on but for now we'll just
make it a capital X so that signals that
this is our actual training data set now
so we'll assume this is the input data
to the neural network and then now what
we're going to define is the two hidden
layers and again they're called a hidden
only because we as the programmer don't
really specify how
that layer we're not in charge of how
that layer changes I suppose like we
kind of defined you know how we defined
the optimizer we define various hyper
parameters for the optimizer and stuff
like that but but the neural network is
responsible for tweaking that whereas
the input data you know a lot of times
what we're going to do as a programmer
is we're gonna scale that maybe between
zero and one or negative one and
positive one and so on for now we'll
just leave it as is but that is going to
be our input data so in this case we'll
say we've got three samples so so that's
that the next thing that we're gonna do
is let's just go ahead and class and
we're gonna call this layer underscore
dense no performance they're required
and then we're going to define our init
method and in this case we'll just pass
self for now and then I'm gonna sit hit
pass and then I'm also going to define
the forward method and again we'll pass
self and then we'll also just say pass
for now and so let's talk about how we
initialize a later so in the case of
neural networks there's kind of two ways
you're gonna initialize a layer the
first is you've got a trained model that
you saved and you actually want to load
in that model so the what happens when
you save a model what all you're doing
is you're actually just saving the
weights and the biases so when you load
the model that's all you're doing is
you're setting the weights and biases as
whatever they were in that saved model
in this case though let's say we're
making a new neural network what how do
we initialize well you've got weights
and biases that need to be initialized
so first we're going to initialize
weights the way that we tend to
initialize weights is as random values
between in the range of negative 1 and
positive 1 but the smaller that range or
the more tight that range is probably
the better we want generally with the
neural networks we want small values so
the reason why we want small values is
we hope that things continue to tend in
the range of negative 1 to positive 1
now just as a single example of why we
do that is if you have input data and
the weight is say 1.2 or 1.5 over 5 or
some larger value what you're doing is
data passes through this network is
you're making it bigger
and then for each of those connections
if each of those weights is above one
you're making it bigger than bigger than
bigger than bigger and then you get this
like explosion so one of the things that
we try to do is keep including with our
input data so in this case we have a few
values that are that exceed the range so
one of the things you might do is first
normalize this data data set and then
scale this data set and by scale we
generally mean take it in and change the
values so that like kind of the meaning
stays the same but the scale has changed
in such a way that these values are all
between negative 1 and positive 1 but we
will talk about that later but in this
case when we initialize our layers we
want to kind of adhere to this principle
of keeping values small rather than
letting them even at the outset just
explode so for our weights you know we
you know maybe something between the
values of negative zero point one and
positive zero point one that's it maybe
a good starting point for weights then
for biases we tend to initialize those
as just zero now there's times where you
might not want to do that because if for
whatever reason your neurons aren't
firing initially so if they they go
through the neural network inputs times
the weights it's not big enough to
actually produce an output your bias
being zero means it's that neuron is
going to output a zero so then what
happens
well that output at zero gets multiplied
by whatever the weight is for the next
you know the next connection zero times
any weight is still going to be 0 if
that neurons bias is also zero it's
going to output a zero and then boom
you've just propagated through this
entire network all zeros and the network
is dead so to speak so if that if you're
having a problem like that just know ok
maybe we need to start the biases off as
a non zero number like I said
in general that won't be an issue but if
that is an issue that is that's one
solution and again that's why we learn
about neural networks from scratch so
that when we hit issues like this we
know it's probably a dead network okay
how do I solve that I maybe want to
initialize biases is something other
than zero
so with that in mind let's do it so for
the weights we want we're gonna use
random and numpy and just so everybody
following along hopefully we'll get the
same values we're going to set MP random
dot seed we're gonna set this to zero so
for initialization we need weights and
biases so we're gonna say self dot
weights and this is going to be equal to
NP random dot R and R and M and then we
need the shape that we want to pass so
in this case we need to know kind of two
things from the programmer when when
this layer is created which is what's
the size of the input coming in and then
what is the size how many neurons do we
want to have so in this case what is the
size of the input coming into this layer
it will be the size of a single sample
so in this case you're gonna pass a
batch but in this case it's four right
so you would say you would say four but
instead what we're going to say is n
inputs to the network and so what we
want from numpy is to create a weights
that will be the size of n inputs
multiplied by how many neurons do we
want to have so we'll say n neurons and
then what we're gonna do is in this in
the parameters that we're gonna add are
gonna be n inputs and neurons so so when
we create the this dense layer we'll
specify these values so that is n P dot
R and R and n n inputs and neurons now
just to show what this does because we
are actually gonna we're gonna make this
even smaller let's go ahead and print
and we'll paste this in and let's just
say the N inputs is 4 and we're gonna
have three neurons we can save and run
that and you can see here is our weights
so what R and n does is just a Gaussian
distribution
bounded around zero but as you can see
some of these values are actually bigger
than one so what we want to do is
instead let's just say zero point one oh
and then run it again why is that not
right there we go ok and then this looks
a little bit more like what we hope our
weights to look like so that's what
we're gonna do here so we're just going
to say zero
times and that will be our weights in
this and again this is just the shape
that it makes for us and then we're
gonna say self dot biases and we're
gonna say that is equal to NP zeros and
in this case our biases the shape is one
by however many neurons that we have so
actually two things to point out before
we move on to this forward method first
of all the the input to MP dot zeros to
pass the shape actually the first
parameter is the shape so we need to
actually pass the actual shape as a
parameter so it'll be just a tuple of
the shape versus NP random dot R and n
where the parameters are the shade so
just kind of note those differences but
actually both of these functions return
a matrix of the shape of you know this
and this and or the shape of this and
this so kind of confusing I almost mess
that up
so make sure you don't so the other
thing I want to point out is the shape
of weights so how did we shape weights
we're saying this matrix is n inputs by
the number of neurons so we're viewing
part three what was the shape of weights
the shape of weights in this case was
actually the number of neurons by the
number of inputs so it's the opposite so
why did we do that so the reason why
we're doing that is when we go to do our
forward pass if we have shaped our
weights and so in this way already when
we do the forward pass we don't have to
do a transpose every time we do a
forward pass it's just a silly operation
to be doing everytime when now we've got
full control right here in the
initialization so what we're going to do
is actually just not need the transpose
anymore it just makes a lot of sense so
take note of that as well so for the
forward method the forward method is
going to just take inputs so whatever
inputs are this could be really one of
two things it's either gonna be if this
is the first hidden layer the inputs are
going to be your actual your your actual
training data or the inputs will be the
self dot output
from the previous layer now the
self-taught output this is going to be
MP dots and in this case it's going to
be your whatever the inputs are
multiplied by these self dot weights and
then of course plus self dot biases and
that is your forward method so let's
make use of this and I will be done with
this tutorial so the first thing we're
going to do is we're gonna make our two
layers so we're gonna say layer 1 equals
a layer dense object and we specify
basically here the size of the inputs
and then the how many neurons do we want
to have so the size of the inputs we
already know that it is so the inputs
it's basically how many features in each
sample so in this case we have 1 2 3 4
so we know the input size is going to be
4 and then for number of neurons it's
anything you want you can make this any
number you want I'm gonna for now just
say 5 so we can look at it on the output
but you could make this 512 it does it
it's whatever you want so and that's why
we want to make this an object because
it's gonna just make so much more sense
it's so much more dynamic so so that's
our layer 1 and then we can go ahead and
just specify our layer 2 now the only
requirement for layer 2 is that the
output from layer 1 is going to be the
input to layer 2 therefore if this is 5
on the output layer 2 has to be of shape
5 for the input but again the output can
be any shape or any size that you want
so we'll say - ok again it could be
anything you want I'm gonna do choose 2
so now we have these two layer objects
now we can pass data through these layer
objects-- and when we do that we get a
self dot output for that layer so first
let's start with layer 1 so we're going
to say layer 1 dot and we'll do a
forward pass or the forward method and
we'll pass in the X data when we do that
that means we will now have a layer one
output value so let's go ahead and print
that so print layer one output
and we can see here that sure enough
because or how big was the data that we
passed we had three samples so we get
three outputs basically of this batch
and each one has how many values well
five because that's how many neurons we
said this later has and again you could
have picked any number here so now layer
one output becomes the input to layer
two so we will say layer two and then we
do dot forward and we will say layer 1
dot output and then what we can do is
print layer 2 dot output and let me just
silence this one so it's super clear go
ahead and run that and what we get is
again of size three because that was the
batch of the input data that we passed
we now get three examples of these two
neuron outputs based on the data that we
passed in so pretty cool this has been a
pretty long time to get to such a basic
concept but as you hopefully you can see
there's so much that even in this super
basic concept of inputs times the way
it's plus bias so much has gone into
that just alone that hopefully at this
point I think it's pretty cool to take
your input data and pass it through this
network and get you know whatever shape
you could possibly desire I just think
that concept alone is actually pretty
cool so anyway that is our dense layer
object at least to the point of doing a
forward pass of some data now at this
point the next kind of major thing that
we're missing is in our activation
functions so right now we're just kind
of passing data we do have these weights
in these biases but the next kind of
major element that we tend to tack on
here is going to be an activation
function so that's going to be the
subject of the next video and then of
course as we continue to build after
that we get to finally trying to figure
out okay well what's the loss of this of
this network and then we start to
determine okay well how can we optimize
these weights and then these biases to
decrease that loss and get the values
that we want so pretty cool stuff to
look forward to beginning to get into
the more sexy parts of deep learning
hope
you guys are enjoying again you can
check out the book at nnf SEO where we
are already at the sexy parts of deep
learning also if you have questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave those below otherwise I will see
you guys in another video
you